[Musique]
l'opération premières pages mises en
place par le département a vu le jour en
2010 une action qui vise à donner le
goût pour la lecture dès le plus jeune
âge
chaque année ce sont près de 5000 livres
qui sont distribués aux familles cette
année le département innove en lançant
un appel à candidatures pour la création
du livre qui sera remis aux bébés donner
la possibilité à tout un chacun qui aime
se lancer dans ce projet d'écriture de
créer un album est donc à savoir que
c'est quelque chose d'innovant pour le
conseil départemental et en même temps
on fait participer donc le public
réunionnais à la création
ça c'est quelque chose d'innovant à
travers cet appel à candidatures le
conseil départemental souhaite
récompenser les participants
le lauréat recevra un prix de 8000 euros
et on va récompenser jusqu'au cinquième
prix c'est-à-dire lauréats 8000 euros et
les quatre hommes auront 500 euros mais
la touche encore positif de cette
opération concours c'est que on pourra
aussi édité en cet album à hauteur de 4
mille deux cents exemplaires
donc vous voyez que c'est vraiment un
tremplin à la création
aujourd'hui vous avez la possibilité de
participer à ce concours avec des
critères qui sont définies donc on vous
amène à aller sur le site auteurs
illustrateurs
à vos plumes
[Musique]